[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor john ross hello friends this is
pastor john ross pastor doug is out
but how about an amazing fact it is well
known that bats fly by
sonar they emit high frequency sounds
which the human ear cannot hear
the returning echo of these sounds
places sound print pictures in their
minds
using this technique a bat can catch a
tiny
fast flying insect the higher the pitch
the smaller the surface its echo can
reveal
some sounds are so high that they can
enable the little bat to detect the
presence of a wire
no thicker than a human hair stretched
across its pathway
then there is the intensity of the sound
the louder it is
the more distant the object that can be
detected
so these calls are generally very loud
but wait if it is necessary for the bat
to make such a loud
sound in order to have it echo back from
some far
distant object how can the bat possibly
hear the echo with its ears
in the midst of all of the racket that
it is making with its mouth
and this is a good question for the
eardrum of the bat
is extremely sensitive it is so
sensitive in fact that just a few of its
own screams
would quickly definite but god has taken
care of the problem
there is a special muscle in the middle
ear of the bat that is attached to one
of three tiny bones
which transmit the vibrations of the
eardrum to the organ in the skull that
convert them into
nerve signals sent to the brain
just as each scream is on the verge of
being emitted
this muscle instantly pulls back that
tiny bone
so that it does not transmit sound from
the outer ear to the inner ear
the eardrum is momentarily disconnected
then after the scream is ended the
muscle relaxes and the bone moves back
into place
thus the only sound that the bat hears
is its own echo this back and forth
motion of this bone can occur more than
a hundred
times a second and it always occurs in
perfect alignment
with the sending of the super short
screams
friends if god cares enough about the
common bat to provide it with this
remarkable ability to hear its own echo
how much more does he care for you stay
tuned for more as amazing facts brings
you this edition
of bible answers life
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
well welcome back friends this is bible
answers live and as you mentioned at the
start of the program pastor doug is out
but
this is a live interactive international
bible study and if you have a bible
related question we would love to hear
from you this evening
the phone line here to the studio is 800
that's 800 god says you can also join us
on facebook
on the amazing facts facebook page and
you'll see the phone
phone number is there on screen if you
have a bible related question
now we opened the program talking about
how god made the bat
uh giving it an ability to hear its echo
even though its screams are so loud and
its ears are so
sensitive and if god did all of this for
the bat
of course this is just one creature if
you study all the different animals god
has made and you see the marvels of
creation
if god cares about the animal so much
how much more does he care for you and i
matthew chapter 10 verse 29 these are
the words of jesus
and are not two sparrows sold for a
copper coin
and not one of them falls to the ground
apart from your father's will
but the very hairs of your head are all
numbered
do not fear therefore you are more
valuable
than many sparrows you know if god cares
about the creation of the animals and
providing for their needs
he cares about you we are close to
living at a
very interesting time of earth's history
we're in the midst of a
worldwide pandemic we're facing some
real
challenges economically there seems to
be social unrest
there are natural disasters happening
and there is a lot of fear in the world
people sense something is happening
something
out of the ordinary but as christians we
should have
an abiding peace and a trust knowing
that god
cares for us and he loves us we have a
book we'd like to send you perhaps
you're a little stressed by what's
happening in the world around you maybe
there are some real concerns you have
for your family maybe for your
career we have a book we'd like to send
you it's called
from stress to joy and it's looking at
some of the wonderful promises that we
find in the bible that god gives us that
he is with us he'll provide for our
needs
the book is called from stress to joy
and we'll be happy
to send this to anyone in north america
i will put in the mail and you'll get it
in the next few days
the number to call is 800-835-6747 that
is our resource phone line
and you can tell them you'd like the
book from stress to joy
and we'll be happy to send it to you
again it's 800 800-835-6747
and ask for the book from stress to joy
if you're outside of north america
you can read the book by simply going to
the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org.com
and look in the free library we have a
number of resources there and you'll be
able to find the book from stress to joy
and you'll be able to read and i think
you'll be richly encouraged
by the promises found in the word of god
that's brought to you in this book
thank you for calling and friends we're
going to go straight to the phone lines
we've got george listening in new jersey
george welcome to the program
hi how you doing tonight all right doing
well thank you for calling
yes first i want to thank you for the
little booklet i got from last week's
show
three steps to heaven i actually got it
within five days so it was pretty good i
got it right away
glad you're already enjoying it uh my
question tonight
is about the expression in genesis it's
mostly in genesis
gathered to his people which is used
sometimes when people
passed away and uh it uh
you know at first to me it seems like
it's referring to burial but there's a
few times that it would imply life after
death at least that's what some scholars
say
for instance when jacob dies near the
end of genesis
it says that jacob was gathered to his
people
but then he wasn't really buried until i
guess many days later
and then there's one more verse before
he answered when abraham died it said he
was gathered to his people but he was
only buried with sarah
so how would you explain that in light
of the belief that
a person sleeps when they die because in
some cases it just doesn't
at least to me refer to their burial you
see what i'm saying sure yeah that's a
good question
first thing to note is that phrase used
in the bible is not always used with
reference to
a good person dying now in the
patriarchs the examples that you gave of
course it's referring to
uh believers and um you know we have
confidence that they're going to be in
heaven
but if you get further on in the old
testament it's referring to the
different kings and sometimes it'll use
the phrase they were gathered to their
people many of those kings were not
righteous and you know we don't
anticipate them being in the kingdom
because it says they do
evil in the sight of the lord so the
phrase gathered to his people simply
means
he dies now again i think you referenced
this a little bit and it's not always
exactly the case but
for most times when a person died they
were buried
back in bible times usually in a cave
and you have the example of abraham and
sarah
it was an interesting procedure they
would wrap the body
and they would place it in the cave put
a stone on the door
and the body would decay and after some
time might be a year or two years
whatever it might be
they would go back into the cave the
only thing then left would be the bones
they would take the bones and place them
in a smaller box
and set it to the side and they would
reuse
the tube so you could have an entire
family
buried in the same tomb or in the same
cave
and it was used over and over again so
the phrase
he was gathered to his people often as a
reference to the fact that
burial back in bible times you were
literally your bones were literally
gathered
with your family or with your ancestors
and
that's kind of where the phrase comes
from but it simply means
the person died it's not a reference to
um
the state of the dead whether a good
person goes to heaven or a bad person
goes to hell
or is this some sort of purgatory that's
not what's been revert
referred to in that verse it's just
simply meaning they died and they were
buried
does that help george thank you uh yes
it does very much so
all right thanks for your call we
appreciate it next quarter that we have
is uh irene
um you know just before i take that call
irene hold on for a second we do have a
study guide that talks about the subject
of
what does the bible say about death and
it's called are the dead really dead
and it's one of our amazing facts study
guides it's part of a great series
of different bible topics and we will
send this to anyone who asks for it it's
an important subject and you'll see why
as you get into it
if you read the study guide
understanding this truth is important
because the devil is going to try and
deceive people
in the last days so knowing what the
bible says about what happens to a
person when he dies
is very important because the devil will
deceive people on this very
issue we'll be happy to send anyone this
study guide it's called are the dead
really dead
it's actually an encouraging study the
number is 800-835-6747
and again you can ask that the study
guide is called are the dead really dead
well get in the mail and send it to you
and of course if you're outside of north
america go to the amazing facts
website you can sign up for the free uh
online bible course which that lesson is
one of
irene is listening from texas irene
welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my call
you're welcome
and your question tonight uh my question
is um
from malachi 310 which says bring the
full size into the storehouse so my
question is
um is it wrong to
take the types and offering and give it
to the offering
instead of giving types separately and
offering separately
so i just take the time offering and
give it to the offer
okay good question do we give our tithes
an offering all at one time
can we include it in one offering
usually what a lot of churches do
is um they will have what they call a
tithe envelope
and most churches have this you can take
a tithe envelope and you can kind of
divide up your funds
in different categories one of the
category is tithe and that's 10
of your increase and then there's
usually other areas that you can
contribute to
it might be church budget it might be
for some outreach in the community
and you can assign a dollar amount for
those different funds
but you can write it all in one check
and you can place it in the offering
plate or if you're going to give online
most churches have a similar format
where you can divide up
your tires and your offerings online so
that it's designated
the reason you want to designate or
separate the tithe from the offerings
is for practical purposes the tithe is
used for the most part
and rightfully so to support the work
of full-time preachers so those
like your pastors evangelists are bible
workers those who
who are in full-time ministry in
preaching teaching the word
they are the ones that are sustained
from the tithe and so
it just makes it easier for the
accountants to have a separation
between ties and offerings does that
help irene
ah yes he does thank you all right
you're welcome you know we do have a
study guide talking about the subject of
tithes and offerings what does the bible
teach is it still applicable
in new testament times and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks
the study guide is called in god we
trust and we'll send that to you the
number is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the study guide
in god we trust and we'll get in the
mail
jerry's listening from texas jerry
welcome to the program
ah pastor ross thanks for taking my call
i appreciate it
just over the weekend i can't give you
the exact scripture for it but the bible
says
we'll know each other as they were when
adam wakes up from his long nap
will he recognize the creator that
walked with him in the garden with the
exception of the
precious holes in his hands and the
scars in his forehead
i absolutely you know if there's anyone
that we're going to be able to recognize
in the resurrection
it's going to be jesus um just the glory
and the light
that will shine forth from him the fact
that the angels
are standing all worshiping him that's
going to make it very clear that this
is our savior this is jesus and see yes
will adam
be able to understand and know jesus uh
absolutely now of course when christ
appeared to adam in the garden of eden
he probably didn't appear in the form
that he took when he
became a man during the incarnation but
uh the aura the fact that he is
worshipped
just the divinity that shines forth from
him
that'll without a doubt make it very
clear to adam uh
who this person is that it is indeed
jesus
ah thank you so much pastor ross all
right you're welcome thank you for your
call jerry
we appreciate that uh we've got chris
listening in
florida chris welcome to the program yes
thank you very much and yours
yeah yeah i said the question is from
prophecy of the daniel okay from chapter
7 and verses 13 and 14
when it talks about uh um
if this is actually worth the sun of man
coming
coming down okay the vision that that
yes daniel said yes so my question is
does it refer to research to jesus okay
yeah let me let me read the verse for
those who are um
you know might be driving daniel chapter
7 verse 13 is the verse you're referring
to and it says i was watching in the
night visions and behold one like unto
the son of man
coming with the clouds of heaven now one
would think hey
son of man this is an indication of
jesus
and there are clouds it would seem like
the second coming of christ
but wait a minute this is not the second
coming let me finish the verse
i was watching the night visions behold
one likened to the son of man coming
with the clouds of heaven and then it
says he
came to the ancient of days and they
that would be the angels brought him
near before him
then to him was given dominion gloria
kingdom that all people and nations and
languages should serve him
his dominion is an everlasting dominion
which shall not pass away
now if you look at just a few verses
previous to that we read verse 13
and verse 14 but if you look a little
earlier in verse 9
daniel invasion says i watched till
thrones were put in place and the
ancient of days was seated his garment
is wiped like snow
the hair of his head was like pure wool
he's thrown a fiery flame
wheels a burning fire verse 10 says a
fiery stream issued and came forth from
before him thousand thousands ministered
unto him ten thousand
times ten thousand stood before him the
court was seated
and the books were opened and then you
reading verse 13
i saw one like unto the son of man so
what's been described here in daniel
chapter seven is very interesting
it's describing a special judgment that
occurs in heaven
just before the second coming of christ
sometimes referred to
as the pre-advent judgment the advent
being the second coming of christ
pre being just before and it uses the
imagery of the temple of the sanctuary
of the holy and the most holy place
and this is describing a special work of
judgment that occurs just before
jesus comes so when one likened to the
son of man
is brought with the clouds of heaven he
came before the ancient of days this is
really describing jesus
entering into the most holy place there
in the presence of his father
for the special work of judgment that
happens just before he comes
he receives the kingdoms of this world
and he comes as king of kings
and lord of lords so this is a unique
prophecy we also see other references
for example in revelation chapter 11
talking about the signing of the seventh
trumpet it talks about this
this judgment pre-advent judgment that
we read about here in the bible
um does that help chris yes yes but it's
a little complicated yes
it is yep the key there is it refers to
him coming to the ancient of days
we know the ancient of days is god the
father one likeness of the son of man
that would be christ so this is talking
about a
special event that takes place a
judgment
that happens in heaven you know we do
have a study guide that
actually deals with this very passage of
scripture and it's just a great study
one of my favorite it's called
the final judgment and it talks about
this
along with some other passages also
revelation chapter 11 and so on
and you'll really enjoy it chris just
call and ask and we'll be happy to get
in the mail
anybody wanting to learn more about what
the bible says about this judgment
it's important for us to understand this
because it ties in with revelation
14 the three angels messages which is
god's last warning message to the world
so
call and ask for it the number is
800-835-6747
and again ask for the study guide one of
the amazing facts is study guide
the final judgment and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
we've got anthony listening from new
york anthony welcome to the program
good evening pastor ross um hi my
question
yes i have a question about the concept
of fearing god
now i know um matthew 10 28
it says um for example fear not them
which kill the body
uh but are not able to kill the soul but
fear him which is able to destroy both
soul and body and hell and that's
referring to god and then but in first
john
chapter 4 verse 18 it says there is no
fear and love
but perfect love casted out all fear
because fear hath torment he the spirit
is not
is not made perfect in love and i was
having a conversation
about uh with someone about you know
fearing god and
you know we were i was of the opinion
that yes
initially when you learn of god you fear
him but when you have a relationship
with him in a deeper relationship you
start
to to you know your relationship is
based off of
love rather than fear of judgment or
fear punishment
and um the other person had the idea
that well
because god is so awesome you need to
fear him you don't want to
trifle with him and you know so forth so
i just want to know is there a balance
between the two
or is it how should we understand the
whole concept yeah that's a great
question of course revelation 14
7 says fear god and give him glory um
the word fear carries with the different
applications
the one would be if you're an unbeliever
and you are unrepentant
there is a certain amount of fear that
you should have because there is a
judgment
so there is going to be a time a day of
accountability so
on the one hand the wicked ought to fear
god because the judgment is coming
on the other hand the righteous who have
trusted in god who are putting their
faith in god
they don't fear in the sense of what the
wicked would experience
but rather for them there is a holy
reverence and
all the more they get to know god
the more they love god but the more
uh the greater god becomes
in in other words when the prophet in
the old testament stood in the presence
of god and he saw god high and lifted up
and the bible says glory fill the temple
the prophet said woe is me for i am
undone
and many times in bible prophecy when
you read about a prophet who catches a
glimpse of the glory of god
he feels his unworthiness and yet there
is a
love and a drawing closer to god so
depending upon where you're at you can
either fear god because
you're unrighteous and you're being
disobedient to him or
you can draw close to him in in awe and
reverence motivated by love so
when the bible says fear god if if
you're
rebelling against god yes you ought to
fear but if you love god
you want to reverence god you want to
stand in awe of his glory does that make
sense anthony
that makes perfect sense and that helps
a lot thank you very much
all right thank you for your call we've
got uh e frank listening from new york
e frank welcome to the program yes uh
good evening pastor ross yes
yes i was just wondering uh uh
i've read in the book of amos that there
was a guy that needed uh
illumination to understand uh well what
his
what prophecy was in the old testament
and i was just wondering do
constellations that's the stellar
constellations
in the universe or in the sky actually
allow us to understand the bible better
do we
actually need constellations to guide us
astronomically through scripture okay do
we need
the stars to have a clear understanding
of who god is well i think the clearest
manifestation of what god is like
is found in the scriptures and in the
person of jesus jesus said if you see me
you've seen the father
so um you know if you want to really
know what god is like
well look at jesus look at his teachings
look at his life look at what he did
but when we see the stars and we realize
how big the universe is
we see how glorious
god is in being able to create all these
things the bible says the heavens reveal
the glory of god
um the clearest manifestation though of
who god is
is found in the bible and in the person
of jesus
but there is also a prophetic
application to this
because we find that one of the signs
that was given that the messiah had come
was a star it talks about a star and it
was a unique star and of course you know
the story about when jesus was born in
bethlehem
the wise men followed the star so in
that sense
it was a specific prophecy referring to
a
sign that the wise men understood to be
the coming of the messiah
so in that sense yes the stars did
reveal
something special about god and probably
that star that the wise men followed was
a
a gathering of angels and their glory
was shining forth but
it did reveal something important to
them does that help
you frank yes uh absolutely
all right thank you again for your call
uh we've got uh let's see
chris calling from florida chris welcome
to the program
hi thanks pastor ross uh yeah quick
question
um my question is really simple is it a
sin
to sell on the sabbath i believe it is
but my question is really about
like what about online like let's say
you have an amazon store
and amazon doesn't allow you to close it
how does that work
okay well that's a good question you
know that's one of the things that a lot
of businesses
have to deal with because especially
through the internet we live
in an international world where people
can order
different products for example online
amazon whatever it might be
you might be in different time zones it
might be the sabbath where you are on
the east coast but it might not be the
sabbath where i am on the west coast
so um somebody might be in australia or
new zealand and their whole
day ahead of where we are here in north
america
so you know it's it's difficult to kind
of turn on and turn
off because you wouldn't know what the
sabbath hours are for everyone
so what a lot of companies do is within
their time
zone that they are in you know they will
hopefully
they hope that people will respect the
sabbath hours and and not purchase
things during
their sabbath hours but it's not quite
practical or possible for them to try
and turn
off the ability for somebody to purchase
something
in every time zone around the world so
it becomes more of a personal decision
that people have to make
whether or not they're going to buy
something does that make sense chris
yeah yeah that makes sense um and so
like here's another question so like uh
so are you saying that basically it's
it you know you should just turn it off
on your sabbath and then everybody else
can figure it out for them
themselves well at the end of the day
it's people have to make their own
decision you know when it's the sabbath
they need to refrain from from buying
it's a little hard for us through the
internet to try and
control that now if i have a company and
the sabbath hours come i might not
fulfill or i wouldn't fulfill those
orders on the sabbath
so the person wouldn't get their orders
during the sabbath hours i wouldn't
fulfill those orders but
for them to place the order it's
difficult for us to try and
uh decide what exactly their sabbath
time is because we're in different time
zones
so do the best because they
basically they have their own
fulfillment where people work 24 7. you
can't tell them not to work you know so
i don't know i just feel kind of weird
about it but hey thanks so much i guess
it's a difficult question to begin with
it is living with technology and these
different uh
abilities to buy things around the world
but hopefully individuals will make the
decision where they won't buy on sabbath
and
it's probably the best that we could do
i see there's others
waiting online we've got henry and cindy
and erwin and don't go anywhere we're
going to get your calls but it's
probably not fair for me right now to
take another call because we're coming
up on our
half an hour break and it'll be a chance
for the different stations to identify
themselves and
um we do want to tell you though that if
you've enjoyed this
program it's not over we have another
half an hour to go
but if you'd like to learn more about
amazing facts maybe this is the first
time you're listening to the program
visit our website it's just
amazingfacts.org or dot
com and it is filled with great bible
study resources
there is videos that you can watch there
is also different materials that you can
read
and it'll help you in your walk with
christ friends as mentioned
the program's not over we're just taking
a short break and we'll be right back
with more bible questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it
at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit
kingdomsandtime.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides
a clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live hello friends welcome
back this is bible answers live pastor
doug is out this evening but
our phone lines are open and we are
happy to take your bible question my
name is john ross
and we're going to go back to the phone
lines we've got henry listening in new
york henry welcome to the program
uh yes good evening pastor ross hi there
uh my
my i'm from the wrong finger my question
is
i uh it's written anywhere in the bible
if you keep secrets
from a member of your family this is a
sin
i kept the secrets for this i have two
secrets
one for 60 years and once for 68 years
i haven't said anything to the members
of my family
okay i want to but i i i'm afraid to
i believe in god's hands all right let
me see if i can kind of share with you a
verse or two on that
um i guess the answer would be is it
depends it depends on several things
first of all if it is a sin
that or somebody has committed against a
member of the family
uh maybe they would not have believed at
the time uh maybe it is 10 15
20 30 years in the past and you've
confessed your sin you have turned away
from that sin
and you have committed your life fully
to christ and the holy spirit is working
in you
you know the bible does tell us in micah
chapter 7 verse 19
that god cast our sins in the depths of
the sea
so when we confess our sins and we
honestly believe
the promise of god that he has forgiven
us and we turn away from the sin
we shouldn't have that come and haunt us
it's in the past it's gone
um and we can have peace but if it is
something that occurred
uh in the past and and maybe it's a
hindrance in your relationship with a
family man but maybe a spouse
and the holy spirit is convicting you
that
in order to clear the air in order to
help your relationship you don't want to
keep secrets especially from your spouse
you might want to prayerfully uh sit
down and share with your spouse or a
family member and say you know there is
something i want to share with you and
you can say you know i've asked for
forgiveness i believe god has forgiven
me but i just feel
the burden of my heart to to share this
with you because i don't want any
secrets between us
but you know that's something that i
think you need to pray about and allow
the lord to lead because
every situation is a little different
god knows um the family member
you know the family remember how they're
going to respond you don't want to make
things worse
so um i would follow the promptings of
the holy spirit there i
there is not a scripture that says you
have to uh bring up something that's in
the past that you've confessed with the
lord and you've been forgiven or
even in your past life before you were a
believer but at the same time if the
holy spirit is convicting you that
you need to clear the air or then
prayerfully consider how the lord would
have you do that
thank you for asking that question henry
it's one that i think a lot of people
wrestle with
uh cindy welcome to the program cindy
from oregon
hi thank you for taking my call you're
welcome
so my question is how do i get over
this overwhelming fear i have of
witnessing
there's been so many times that i think
i should say something
and i don't because either i'm afraid of
being ridiculed
or i'm afraid i'm going to say the wrong
thing and
um turn people farther away from god
then rather than bringing them
closer or i'll get into a
topic or discussion that i don't know
enough about
and i so i do nothing i say nothing
okay how do you get over the fear of
witnessing well um
i'll share with you something that i
like to do that i think has helped um
even if a person is not necessarily
religious that you're visiting with but
they are your friend you get to know
them they trust you and they're willing
to share with you a genuine concern that
they have maybe a problem maybe a
financial situation whatever it might be
you get to know them and they share a
concern maybe a family member that's
sick
one of the things that you can say to
pretty much anyone when they share
genuine concern you can say i understand
the way you feel
i would probably feel the same if i was
in your situation
but i have found that god answers
prayer i'm going to pray about that
now it doesn't really matter how they
respond
uh you can tell them that you're going
to pray for them in that situation
sometimes the conversation might not go
any further
on religious things because you know
they might not be a believer and they
kind of roll their eyes and say yeah
yeah whatever
but i found that if if i say that to
someone
and then of course i go home and i pray
for them specifically and i pray that
god will somehow reveal himself to the
person through this situation
and then i allow a week or two weeks to
go by and and in the conversation i'll
bring it up i'll say you know
that situation that you shared with me
about your mother that was sick or your
aunt whatever it might be that financial
need you know i've been praying about
that situation has god done
anything yet and you'll be surprised
the response that people will give you
sometimes they'll say huh you've been
praying about it huh or
maybe god has resolved the situation and
that kind of opens them
up to want to hear more about spiritual
things
so that's that's one of the approaches
that that i've used very
effectively in trying to open up a
religious conversation
okay so then does that mean that
witnessing doesn't necessarily
mean active preaching no i mean you
you've got to share when people are
wanting to receive it or open to receive
it
you can't force someone who might not
have an interest in religious things
but if they respond positively and they
say uh
wow you've been praying about that does
god always answer prayer and
then you can actually start talking to
them about spiritual things and maybe
that would lead to a bible study where
you can sit down with them
and open the word so you can always
share your own personal testimony
you can share with them bible verses of
encouragement
but the first step is get to know them
win their confidence
this is what jesus did he won their
confidence and then he was able to
share with them follow me so we make
friends we win their confidence we meet
their needs
and then we're able to share with them
the word as the holy spirit opens up the
opportunity
okay all right okay that yeah yeah thank
you they're working
actually yeah give it a try i think
you'll be
you'll be surprised it's kind of neat
you know you just pray for people
and see what the lord does and then
follow up uh sometimes we neglect to
follow up and
uh you know we don't see the lord work
because we don't follow up so follow up
an essay i've been praying for you
what has god done in that situation and
i think you'll be encouraged
uh we've got erwin listening from uh las
vegas oh and welcome to the program
good evening pastor ross how are you i'm
well thank you and your question tonight
um how can i make it official with the
lord
when i fast is there a christian ritual
to follow
and get credited officially okay well
remember that
fasting for the christian doesn't earn
merit with god
there is nothing we can do to earn merit
with god uh
salvation is a gift it's god's goodness
it's his grace that saves us but
there are times and it's very
appropriate for us to fast and pray
if we have a particular burden on our
heart if there is a request or if we're
praying for someone else
or if we're praying for a situation that
we might be going through in our lives
it's appropriate to
set aside a day and say lord i'm gonna
i'm gonna really
focus today on seeking your presence
maybe we're wanting to just grow closer
to the lord and we might say lord i'm
going to fast on this day or i might
even fast this afternoon
i'm going to spend some time in prayer
and i want you to reveal to me those
things in my life that might be out of
harmony with your will
and that's very appropriate to do so
there is nothing that you have to
do in order to say hey lord i'm going to
fast
but really it's a matter of prayer and
making that decision and saying lord i'm
going to set aside food for a period of
time whether it's a day or
afternoon or maybe two three days
whatever it might be
and saying lord i'm really going to set
this time aside to seek your presence
i want to seek guidance from you i want
to know what your will is for my life
and that's very appropriate to do so
erwin there's nothing you have to
officially kind of do but just pray
about it and say lord i'm going to
set aside some time for prayer and
you'll be encouraged by what happens
does that make sense
yes thank you it's great to be now
all right thanks for calling erwin uh we
do have a book talking about
prayer and uh we'll send this to anyone
who asks it's written by pastor doug
it's called teach us to pray
and it deals with some of these themes
of prayer also fasting and all
some of those things connected with
seeking revival we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who asks again the book
is called teach us to pray
and the number to call is 800
800-835-6747
and just ask for the book called teach
us to pray and we'll get in the mail
and you'll be encouraged by reading that
we've got stephen listening from georgia
stephen welcome to the program
stephen are you there stephen from
atlanta
hear me i can hear you now yes i
apologize i had it
um muted oh no problem um i have uh
thanks for taking my call
first all and my question actually comes
from genesis
where god is talking to adam
and he's telling them about the tree of
knowledge of good and evil
and he says that thou shalt not eat of
it okay
and then later on in the passage it
talks about where christ
created eve caused adam to go into his
sleep and then we skipped down to
chapter three
starting at verse two going to verse
three
and the woman um said unto the serpent
we may eat at the fruit of the trees of
the garden
but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden god
hath said here's my
point in question ye shall not eat of it
neither shall ye touch lest you die
now i i grew up with the understanding
that the first sin was
where you know eve in her mind conceived
on
actually eating the fruit but she's
saying that god said
that you could not touch it now there's
no reference that god said that so my
question is
is the first sin technically a lie all
right good
live good question i'm saying yep good
question now
um it appears that when god said you
know this tree in the middle of the
garden you're not to eat of the fruit
the bible says that he's he said that to
adam
now there were other things that god
said to adam that you know we don't have
recorded
it's very possible that adam then
communicated to eve
what god had said and god might have
said don't eat it
matter of fact adam might have said
don't even touch it don't even go near
it
god could have very well have said don't
don't even touch the tree
we might not have that recorded now was
that the first lie
i don't believe it was because this
occurred before
sun had entered into the world she was
just being tempted at that time and
temptation is not a sin so um no it
wasn't the first lie god must have made
it very clear
to adam and eve that not only were they
not to eat of the fruit they weren't
even to touch the fruit they weren't
even to open up that door for temptation
we just don't have it recorded and of
course in the lord's spirit says lead us
not in temptation meaning
lead us away from our temptation so
no i don't think this was a lie that eve
said she was sincere
in what she told the serpent god doesn't
even want us to touch the fruit
okay thank you very much for your time
no problem good question thank you
stephen
we've got oliver listening in st louis
missouri hi oliver
hi good evening and blessings to you
pastor ross thank you for taking my call
you're welcome uh my call my question
comes from
a question that had been recently posed
to me
someone recently asked me if i thought
that those who
had died uh in sodom and gomorrah
and i expanded the question to those who
died
by judgment in the flood whether or not
they would be resurrected to face
judgment again
when the lost are raised to
face judgment okay is there going to be
a final judgment that
everyone including those before the
flood
are going to be raised yes we call that
the great white throne judgment you can
read about in revelation chapter 20
and 21 it occurs at the end of the 1000
year period
known as the millennium uh the new
jerusalem comes down from god out of
heaven
and there is a resurrection that takes
place
where all the wicked are outside the new
jerusalem
the righteous are inside the new
jerusalem and the bible refers to this
great white throne and there is this
judgment that takes place
so yeah they will be judged for what
they have done
uh of course their destruction in sodom
and gomorrah
they were judged because of the evil
that they were doing
but they might have also inflicted pain
or suffering on others
and they have not given account for that
so there is going to be a final day of
judgment
that occurs um at the end of the
thousand years
okay thank you pastor all right you're
welcome thanks oliver we do have a study
guide talking about
this judgment and it's actually a
thousand years of peace
it's talking about the 1 000 year
millennium
and you read about in revelation chapter
20. we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who asks as part of our amazing
facts study guide series it's called a
thousand years of peace the number is
800-835-6747 asked for the study guide
called a thousand years of peace
we've got chris in florida chris welcome
to the program
hi chris you there chris from
florida going once going twice
all right we might come back to chris
let's try fred in california fred
welcome to the program
fred in california you there
uh yes i'm here oh okay good yes we can
hear you good evening all right
good evening pastor rasa there's a
question
in one of my uh attending my bible study
group
and somebody asked him what's your
question there are two
people the other one is uh you know had
accepted christ
and the other one has not accepted yet
but the one that i'm not accepted yet is
more successful
in his business and in everything that
he does
while the one that accepted jesus christ
can barely
get anything for for his family so
how do i answer that and what would be
the
the best bible verse that i can probably
use okay good question why does it seem
that
the wickets sometimes prosper and the
righteous seem to suffer
uh one might answer well is god being
fair well of course the
the reason why somebody chooses to
follow god isn't just
for temporary blessings what god
promises us
is eternal life that is the greatest
blessing that anyone can have
in addition to the promise of eternal
life for those who believe in christ
jesus promises to give us a peace that
passes all understanding
he promises to be with us and give us
strength and guidance
he doesn't promise us that we will
always be
richly blessed in this life because we
live in a world that's filled with sin
he doesn't promise that we won't suffer
persecution or tribulation
actually jesus says that those who
follow him especially in the last days
will face
persecution and trials and difficulties
why does it seem that the wicked
sometimes prosper well the bible says
god makes his
reign to fall on the righteous and the
unrighteous
sometimes even though someone might be
unrighteous they might have good common
sense and
they might have talents or abilities to
be productive in business or whatever
their work might be
you know god does promise to provide for
our needs
so i believe it can trust that god will
provide for him
jesus says your brain your water will be
sure but that doesn't guarantee that
we're going to be
richly blessed in material things here
on this earth
but that should not be our motivation
for serving god we serve god because he
loves us
and because he is righteous and because
he died
to save us and we have hope of eternal
life
that's the true motivation for the
christian does that make sense for it
it makes a lot of sense in other words
what what we are trying to really say is
that
the the measure of god's uh you know uh
blessings it's not only in just one area
or it's just right in the financial but
it's more of a lot of areas in our life
that
we can get blessing from god absolutely
you know jesus said what is the prophet
a man that would gain the whole world
and lose his own soul and lost his
sunshine
so thank you so much all right you're
welcome thank you fred for
for your call you know we do have a
study guide that talks about finance and
the christian it's called in god we
trust i mentioned this study guide a
little earlier
and it does talk about how that god
promises to provide for our needs
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone looking for those bible verses
just call and ask for the study guide
it's called in god we trust
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and ask for the study guide in god we
trust we've got
denny listening in minnesota danny
welcome to the program
oh pastor ross so nice to talk to you
again
hey thanks a lot yes
my wife kind of stumped me with a bible
question today and i didn't have a great
answer for it i needed your assistance
of your expertise all right we'll try
yeah john 5 17. could you read that and
explain that to her for me
sure we'll take a look at john 5 17
it says but jesus answered them and said
my father has been working until now
and i have been working therefore the
jews sought all the more to kill him
because he not only broke the sabbath
but he said that god was his father
making himself equal with god
now of course jesus didn't break the
sabbath he was faithful to the fourth
commandment
but the jews who had added all these
man-made traditions
for the sabbath christ didn't follow
their tradition so in their minds
he was breaking the sabbath but you're
wondering about verse 17
my father has been working until now and
i also have been working
yes uh what did that what does that
exactly mean that they were working
okay remember the point of controversy
that was taking place if you just look
back a little bit
jesus had healed someone on the sabbath
he had said take up your beard and walk
and they accused jesus of breaking the
sabbath because he healed someone
and jesus says well my father works
there are certain things that have to
take place on the sabbath
uh god sends the rain on the sabbath the
crops will grow on the sabbath
you know the animals still
have to produce milk the cows or
whatever it might be so god is still
providing for the needs of his people
on the sabbath and one of the greatest
needs that god provides
is salvation that's what he wants to do
wants to provide salvation for people
and he provides healing when somebody is
sick
god doesn't rest on the sabbath to heal
them but god continues
to work through his spirit so yes jesus
is just simply saying that my father
is working on the sabbath to do good and
that's why jesus said
it is good to do good on the sabbath day
on the sabbath now thank you pastor rob
really helped okay well thank you denny
we appreciate your call
uh let's see we've got uh kathy
listening in new york kathy welcome to
the program
yes good evening how are you i'm doing
well thank you for calling
good my question is in regards to second
corinthians
chapter 5 verse 8 wherever it says
to be absent from the body is presence
with the lord
what does that exactly mean okay so here
we have paul writing to
the believers in in corinth and he says
he's talking about death
and he says to be absent from the bodies
to be present with the lord
when a person dies their very next
conscious
thought is the resurrection and the
second coming of christ
the bible says flesh and blood cannot
inherit the kingdom of god
so when a person is resurrected at the
second coming
they are raised with glorified bodies
uh with the same body that jesus had
after he rose from the dead
where he appeared to the disciples and
he just kind of appeared before them
he didn't have to go through the door he
just appeared in the room with him
so this glorified body is what we have
in the resurrection paul says to be
absent
from this body is to be present with the
lord meaning the resurrection has taken
place and i am present with the lord i
have this new body
that god has given me what we need to
recognize is that
the bible speaks of death as being as
asleep and when a person is asleep
they're unaware of time
they don't know what's going on around
them the very next thing they know
is they are awakened the alarm goes off
in the morning it's time to get up
so likewise a person who dies their very
next conscious thought
is if they if they save the next
conscious thought is the presence of the
lord jesus is coming in the clouds he
calls forth his sleeping saints
they are resurrected with these immortal
bodies forever to be with the lord
now where does theon's soul go after you
die
all right well the bible speaks of the
soul as being
the being the living person you've got
the breath
for example in genesis when god made
adam it says he formed him out of the
dust of the earth god breathed into him
the breath of life or the spirit
and man became a living soul
so a living soul refers to a living
being
so we are all living souls we are living
beings when a person dies
the soul doesn't go anywhere the soul
just simply ceases to exist
until the resurrection and then god once
again
breathes the breath of life into the
body
now a glorified body and we become
living beings so um so
i guess my question should have been
where does
the breath go okay the breath is also
referred to
yes the breath is also referred to in
the bible as the spirit
and that is the essence of life every
living being
shares the breath of life that god has
given us only god
can create life we can perpetuate life
but god creates life and so that that
power of life to be a living being
whether you're
saved or lost or whether even if you're
an
animal you're alive that that spark of
life that breath of life
comes from god when a person dies that
spirit that breath of life returns to
god who gave it
but it doesn't mean that your emotions
or your mind or your ability to
think goes along with that it's just
that that spark of life that
all living things share god creates us
god gives us life
okay thank you that clarifies it i
appreciate it
well thank you for calling kathy you
know i think you'd really enjoy
the study guide that we have it's one of
the amazing facts study guides it's
called are the dead really dead
and it talks about what does the bible
say happens to a person when they die
can they come back can a person
haunt someone else if they are dead what
does the bible teach on that
what does the bible say about ghosts
well we'll be happy to tell you
take a look at that study guide call
800-835-6747
and you can just ask for that study
guide it's called are the dead
really dead i think you'll be encouraged
we also have a website i want to tell
you about it's called
deathtruth.com justdeathtruth.com
go to their website.coma.org i think
it's the same
and you'll be able to read the study
guide right there on the website you'll
be able to watch
some videos talking about the subject of
what happens when a person dies
you'll be able to get some wonderful
bible verses and bible studies on that
so yes please take a look at their
website it's called deathtruth.com
and again friends we want to thank you
for joining us tonight i know there are
some still
waiting and i'm sorry we didn't get to
your calls tonight but hopefully you'll
give us another chance next week we're
going to be here
we believe it'll be a live program and
we're looking forward to taking your
bible questions so
for those of you that we weren't able to
get to your question tonight please
call us again next week until then i
want to encourage you to take a look at
our website
amazingfacts.org or dot com it's filled
with great resources
and if you've been blessed by this
program we do appreciate your support to
keep us on the air
you can just donate right there at the
website amazingfacts.org
till next week god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible
even better than before bible answers
live
is produced by amazing facts
international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore
in nearly every country and culture
egyptians built pyramids to help guide
the spirits of their leaders
rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead
even the bible tells of a king that used
a witch
to contact the spirit of a deceased
prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions
have gone from mere superstitions to
mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organizations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings
trying to prove once and for all the
existence
of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world
there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
[Music]
why do these stories persist
does it even matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out
for yourself visit deathtruth.com
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country
come together to reveal the hidden
history of the book of revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects
this 95-minute masterpiece brings to
life the book of revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery
get your copy today visit itunes or
afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-830
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
you